that
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
Spaceport here in French Guyana and to
your front row seat for the launch of
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer on an
Arion 5 rocket
[Music]
our rocket is here on the launch pad
with the juice spacecraft on top ready
to begin is drumming
over the next couple of hours we will
renew live coverage of launch operations
directly from here the Jupiter control
center
and from here
control at the European space operations
center in Germany
[Music]
getting the first signals from the
spacecraft after launch and confirmation
that the solar panels have deployed
we'll be discussing exactly what makes
this spacecraft so special
I'm Matt Russell I'm Bruno Souza I'm
Rafael and I'm Lisa Peterson and welcome
to flight VA 260 on the first leg of
Juicy's journey into space
following yesterday's postponement due
to bad weather Ariane 5 is now ready for
launch here at Europe's Spaceport in
French Guyana with her single passenger
the Jupiter icy moons Explorer juice
safe and sound under the fairing liftoff
is scheduled in just under half an hour
I'm right here in the aptly named
Jupiter mission control room this is the
nerve center of today's Mission and you
can see here on the other side of this
protective glass which we call the
Fishbowl here in Kuru you can see the
teams working hard on the last
preparations towards today's Mission
opposite me here we have the partners
VIPs and guests all comfortably seated
and waiting for liftoff and with me
right here for an update we have Stefan
Israel CEO of Aryan space welcome Stefan
good morning please thank you very much
so we're back here together so can you
first of all maybe tell me 24-hour delay
what was the reason for this delay
yesterday so very simple the launcher
was ready juice was ready the launch was
ready but the weather was not with us
you know we have to monitor to risk IRT
to the winds and it was okay but risk of
lightning yesterday was a real risk with
the cloud
to Monitor and so we have made the
decision not to lift off yesterday but
of course as we always say better be
safe than sorry Jews can absolutely
afford to wait another day under the
fairing not a problem for sure because
you know that once we will have done our
job after 27 minutes and once we will
have our bitty the juice on an escape
orbit then it will be the start of an
eight-year Journey so one day is no
fingers compared to what we have ahead
of us we would monitor the weather now
in the final minutes so teams have
worked all night all these read up to
now so we are now all is green up to now
I'm sorry and we can see it on the state
of school and we get some cutting here
it's a path of emotion for such an
important Mission it's going to bring us
very good luck yeah absolutely great and
so at 9 14 we will lift off at 9 14
we'll lift off thank you so much Stefan
and fingers crossed good luck for today
and we'll see you later thank you so
much Stefan
is getting a round of apples in here in
Jupiter
of course an emotion which is easy to
understand obviously considering the
conditions of yesterday's delay but
everything is fine safe and sound under
the fairing as we said so as the teams
working here in Jupiter control more
than seven thousand kilometers away over
the Atlantic at uh esa's Mission Control
Center in darmstadt Germany we have the
teams there who will take over control
of the aircraft once it separates from
the mothership and we're going to go
straight over and speak to them and hear
how things are looking over there in
damage that over to you Matt
uh thank you Lisa and hello to all our
Watchers welcome to esoc the European
space operations center uh here in
darmstadt Germany in the heart of
Mission Control I am my name is Matt
Russell and I'll be your host for the
second half of this juice broadcast me
and behind we have Bruno Souza in the
actual control room itself so I went
hello Bruno uh try and give us an update
of what's happening in there at the
moment
hi Matt we're still getting Goosebumps
all day although to this time a bit more
cautious Goosebumps but we are ready to
go and in fact just a few minutes ago
the flight director Andrea Komatsu just
did the roll call and got to go from
everybody here in the room we have some
footage of that and we're gonna replay
it for you
to all stations this is a day on The
Briefing Loop for the Roll Call
please reply on my call with your call
sign and your status gonna go
om o m go some some go data handling
and data handling
CS go platform platform go fly Dynamics
go project rep project rep go project
support project support go soft code
soft code go software support software
support go abstract Instagram scheduling
scheduling go thanks this completes the
roll call for the Jewish Mission we'll
go for launch
so as you just saw we are fully ready to
go we're just waiting for that rocket to
get off the launch pad
thanks so much Bruno well we're running
out of time here so we're back over to
you Lisa in crew and a massive good luck
to you
thank you from the teams in darmstadt
and hey the pressure's on they said all
we're waiting for is that rocket to take
off well they've told us they're ready
the rocket is ready but we want to know
about juice and we have Michaela Babu
from ASA who's here to tell us all about
it Michaela how ready is juice good
morning juice is actually ready and
excited to start this journey as we
speak my colleagues are closely
monitoring the satellites so yesterday
after the launch postponed the satellite
was switched off and slowly in the day
around 7 14 PM it has been turned on to
start the countdown procedure they are
very close to us a few kilometers away
in LBC control room and everyone is
hoping for good mother specs
fantastic so we have a bit of time to
chat about this so um your job is
schedule controller does that mean that
you're in charge of making sure all goes
to plants
it's part of my responsibility but you
know when it comes to scheduling is
never one single person's job it's
actually a team exercise because
planning means working coherently as a
team and us the juice projecting we are
quite uh already schedule oriented we
have a strong planning mindset and
um even if you have the most perfect
plan you always have risk you have
uncertainty and we saw that yesterday so
imagine if you take a step back Us in
Jews we had to run our AIT campaign
through a pandemic and if you think of
the industrial Consortium more than 2
000 people worked on this program 23
countries 18 institutions 83 companies
then you understand the complexity of
project management that my colleagues
and I have been performed on this
Mission and done a fantastic job so far
so this is a personal Journey for you
it's eight years your entire
professional life because you're just a
baby so tell us how are you feeling
today I'm very excited and yes juice is
my entire career in Isa and yesterday as
the project team we received so much
positive energy from home from our
science projects thank you so much for
your wishes everyone in this deck we saw
you how many were there thank you for
your support as dog as Zach the people
on the Spaceport we managed to see our
extended juice family our instrument
colleagues and we spoke with them so
they gave us all the energy to go
through the night and to keep just ready
for the launch today
and thank you so much I've got a last
word before we we leave it here I wish
everyone to enjoy the launch from from
all the teams who have worked on this
amazing journey as European I'm
exceptionally proud to be part of it and
let's enjoy the event of today it's well
deserved absolutely well deserved for
your teams and of course all the other
teams that you mentioned that have been
working on this project thank you so
much Michaela thank you so um as
mihailing was saying a huge huge amount
of work from teams all over the world
we're going to find out more about these
teams achievements and of course about
juice in the next film
thank you
Jupiter the largest planet in the solar
system is a place that holds many
Secrets this fascinating gas giant
planet and its intriguing moons have
raised more questions than answers
today these answers are in essa's grasp
with the very first European mission to
Jupiter
juice
short for Jupiter icy moons Explorer
this spacecraft will explore Jupiter and
three of its icy moons Callisto Europa
and in particular Ganymede developed and
built by Airbus producer spacecraft is
equipped with 10 top-of-the-line science
instruments to explore the jolian system
and investigate whether some of its many
environments may be suitable for the
formation of life
this Grand Odyssey of exploration begins
with the launch of juice on an Aryan 5
rocket from Europe's Spaceport in karoo
an historical Mission aiming at solving
key Mysteries such as the possibility of
life in the Jovian system ganymede's
magnetic field and last but not least
the formation of Jupiter and its moons
juice will also study Jupiter's complex
weather chemistry and climate in detail
it's a very fantastic Mission from the
scientific point of view very broad
science very interdisciplinary science
we would like to see whether around
Jupiter there are places where life
could have started to explore that we
need to find a place with the internal
energy and with liquid water and inside
the icy moons we have good reason to
believe that there is in fact more
liquid water out there inside the
surface than on on Earth
private Jupiter Jupiter 2031 and will
then make its Jupiter Tour and Moon's
flybys before orbiting Ganymede this
will be the first time a spacecraft
orbits any Moon other than our own
during its Journey Juice will face many
dangers such as Jupiter's intense
radiation belts or its large
gravitational pull but these dangers
will be worth it for the science that
juice will uncover
the gas giant will reveal some of its
many secrets in 2032 when the First Data
will be available
watch this space
So speaking of space exploration we have
two of the faces of human face
Exploration with us here today I'm
delighted to welcome once again to Mark
pesky and Matthias thank you very much
gentlemen for being with us again today
it's a pleasure so we're seeing Jews go
up into space with these outstanding
instruments what is it about sending
this kind of instrument going out to
space yourselves that helps us back here
on Earth
yeah I think space exploration really in
space takes all the boxes you've got all
the short terms benefits you know the
things that we all use that we all have
you know smartphones the navigation the
weather report
and then you have the more medium term I
would say applications the reason we
know today about climate change the
reason we're in position to fight
climate change thanks to all the
missions we send around yours in
observing years so that's kind of the
more medium terms uh space agencies are
the champions or fighting against
climate change and then you have the
longer term the longer term the
far-reaching benefits for the future and
that's the research and the exploration
we're doing the research on board the
space station building better materials
you know better medicine better
treatments and it all diffuses in
society on Earth and it's going to make
the progress you know go up one step at
a time and then those missions going far
out into the solar system it's really to
look at ourselves our place in the
universe how do planets form where do we
come from where are we going those are
very important questions and those are
the type of questions that we're trying
to solve with those missions
fantastic well we're talking about juice
today that's going about to lift off and
go on its Mission a long long journey
but what about human space exploration
what are the next destinations well I
think the next destination issue is very
much the Moon I mean the next big thing
in space space exploration human space
exploration is the Artemis program he
says a big part has a big part to play
an Artemis program we're providing the
European service module to the Orion
capsule that means one day we'll see
European astronauts around the Moon on
the moon and so to prepare for this we
also have a robotic Moon exploration and
then what we learn on the moon will put
us in a position one day to go to Mars
and Mars is the twin sister of the earth
that's where we learn a lot on ourselves
it had similar conditions it has lost
his atmosphere liquid water also has
disappeared can it happen to us you know
those are important questions and that's
why we'll go to Mars first with our Pros
with our orbiters and then one day with
human exploration to Mars that's the the
big prize money the Big Goal the big
step fantastic wow it's a it makes you
dream but of course what I would like to
know from you Matthias is
um are you guys getting ready to take
part in these Adventures yes so tomorrow
and I we already to a lowest orbit and
flying to the Moon we need to learn more
because on the moon you need geologists
so we need to go out in the field and
learn how to talk with sign that was the
geologist how to beat the hands and the
eyes of the geologist once we're on the
surface of the Moon and Isa already
started this training for European
astronauts some years ago and so we see
continuously European astronauts going
out into the field learning all these
skills but we also need to develop
facilities where we can train European
astronauts what to do on the moon and so
in Cologne we will now have the lunar
the moon training facility which will
enable like to do all this training over
there and it will be so good that even
hopefully the NASA astronauts will come
over to train there like for their
Artemis Mission so that's the big Vision
that we have but it's not only learning
for the moon we also like also keep in
Focus that we have European astronauts
flying to the ISS Andy morgenson is
getting ready to fly later this year and
we just started a new astronaut class
they will be flying to the ISS hopefully
and to whatever comes after the ISS
so uh are you do you imagine yourself
taking off from here in uh spent for the
from the European Spaceport here in
French Guiana one day Matthias yes we
are currently in times that are really
like a revolution in space and so Europe
needs to step up in one of the big
missions that we have we need to become
Missouri to become autonomous also with
access to space for Europeans from
European soil and I think French Korean
is the ideal place to send Europeans on
the European rocket inner European
capsule to space it's our big dream
Tamara and I we would love to fly
together from here to lowest orbit but
maybe even also in European rocket
further towards the moon and you said
you'd be happy to welcome your NASA
friends as well absolutely I mean it's
like we should not forget
um space flight is also a soft diplomacy
power and we will see very soon that
China will invite foreign astronauts to
fly to their space station and so we
Europeans we are just learning that in
these times it becomes more and more
important to be on level Feud playing
and space flight definitely is also an
important part in the in the diplomacy
area huge thank you Matthias and we have
with us Joseph you are the director
general of Issa thank you for joining us
so in a nutshell here what we've been
talking about is Europe's capabilities
for independent launch uh are you going
to make this happen
it's not for me to make it happen it's
all the others to make it happen but
certainly we have been uh working very
hard on it we have consulted experts
independent experts to help us giving
advice what this would mean for Europe
as a Unity of all the countries the
inspiration we would give the economic
benefits the geopolitical strength that
would be portrayed through such a
negativity so there's a lot of
interesting facets and we have just
heard Matthias and uh and Tomah talking
about those because it's so important
and yes we are working on it but let's
talk about shoes because that's why
we're here also another excellent server
Europe is really good and let's look how
our satellites and our launches are
doing thank you very much gentlemen huge
thank you thank you and to talk about
juice I am joined by from Aryan space
Rafael is going to take us step by step
all the way through every step of the
mission Raphael hello Liz hello welcome
to road to space and I'm going to let
you take over from here and tell us what
the next steps are yes so this morning
we are launching towards the east where
we benefit from the slingshot effect
given by the rotation and of the earth
so the launcher performs a first pitch
maneuver in order to get us into the
right direction and only two minutes and
17 seconds after liftoff the two
boosters have done their jobs of
providing the main thrust so we don't
need them anymore they are detached from
the launcher
shortly after that the fairing which
protecting the spacecraft
from the environment of the launch is
also jettisoned as we have crossed the
limits of the atmosphere once the
launcher reaches an intermediate orbit
the main stage is cut off and separated
so then the upper stage takes over
which engine is going to power for about
16 minutes in order to raise speed and
altitude and release juice on the
targeted orbits so by the way the little
towers that you see on the motion
picture they represent a chain of
telemetry stations that are receiving
data from the rn5 in real time all along
the flight path
after some orientation Maneuvers and
juice is separated on a liberation's
orbit it means that it will have the
required speed to escape literally the
gravitational approval of the Earth
then this is almost the end of the
mission from the launcher as we still
need to perform some disposal maneuvers
of the upper stage but juice is only
beginning its Journey
either teams will use the northier Grant
Elementary stations in Australia to
acquire the signal from the spacecraft
and take full control of it
one hour and a half after liftoff Jewel
will start deploying itself like a
butterfly into space
first it will unfold the large solar
panels their total surface is 85 square
meters this is definitely bigger than my
Parisian apartment
and then in the following days it will
deploy its many antennas and probes so
the animation here doesn't respect the
increasing altitude that juice is gonna
get getting farther and farther from
Earth
on its way to its eight-year journey to
Jupiter thank you so much Rafael it's
all very clear and actually as Raphael
was speaking so you can see the pictures
of Aryan on the launch pad as Raphael
was speaking we hit the next milestone
in our video transfer in our sorry in
chronology which is of course the -10
weather update and yes I'm looking at
the board
anything in my earpiece I didn't see
anyone picking up a mic
so it's looking good so far it is green
and we're good to go so we take like
Stefan said we are usually checking the
wind at high altitude and doing in the
vicinity of the launch pads and also the
risk of lightning yesterday it is the
risk of lightning that prevented us from
launching but today everything's good
we're good to go we can continue the
operations that sounds great and
continuing the operations means that
we're heading towards what we call the
synchronized sequence we'll talk about
that in just a minute
um so there's another team you see the
teams working here uh final preparation
on the way here in Jupiter control but
of course there's another team at the
launch control center which is much
closer to the launch it's about four
three four kilometers to the launcher
and they've been working since last
night they've not slept tell us more
about them well these teams are
monitoring all the operations during The
Final Countdown so for example they are
feeding the cryogenic stages they're
cooling the Vulcan engine that's the
main engine of the launcher they are
pressurizing the upper sphere upper
stage sphere this is them how I work in
the morning exactly and I think the
image is were shot this morning actually
and so it's all these operations that
are leading us to the start of the
synchronous sequence
so what is this synchronized sequence
Raphael well it's a really crucial step
you have 30 seconds yeah so I'm going to
make it very quick it's basically a
succession of operations aimed at giving
more and more autonomy to the launcher
and to set it in its flight
configuration yeah because 30 seconds
and the reversible once we've started
the synchronized sequence we can't go
back no so we are going absolutely and
we're going to now wait and here
foreign
so then we heard it from the DDO who is
the range operations manager we'll talk
about him in a minute and he's just
announced the start of the synchronized
sequence just a quick question why does
it have to happen at -7 we were just
saying well I mean this is obviously not
a magic number this is just the time for
all these last minutes operations to be
performed for example we are topping up
the and pressurizing the tanks and we
switched the power supply from ground to
board and only then the launcher is
going to be fully awakened for launch
fantastic um
for those who are joining who are
joining us we are six minutes and 20
seconds to lift off of Ariane 5 carrying
juice on the first leg of its journey
into space and towards Jupiter as
Raphael was saying Ariane we were
talking about this earlier Arya normally
launches uh two passengers but this time
it's a single passenger so can you just
go quickly into what difference that
makes for the launcher oh for the
launcher this is so a very precious
passenger but for the launcher it
remains exactly the same you have the
two lateral boosters you have the main
stage you have the upper stage one
fairing we are also launching towards
the east which is the same direction as
for standard telecommunication
satellites only the final destinations
is a bit different this is Jupiter
um so yeah it is the last time that we
performed
such a single configuration one of the
last time was for launching the Space
Telescope gem sweat let's hope to today
is going to be as Flawless and smooth
absolutely and that's quickly now go
into the film and have a look at the
last couple of months of launch
preparations
four months ago elements of the Aryan
type rocket arrived by boat on the coast
of crew
they were carefully transferred to
Europe's Spaceport in large containers
these elements were then assembled in a
dedicated building
here we see the main core being placed
into a vertical position standing 31
meters high
were attached to either side of the main
stage
followed by the upper cryogenic stage
hoisted into the air and lowered onto
the main stage
the whole assembly was then moved to the
so-called final Assembly Building
Jews arrived last February by planning
Cayenne the main city of French Guyana
it then traveled an additional 50
kilometers to the Spaceport for
preparation
there spacecraft was removed from its
container and carefully inspected in
clean room facilities
foreign
[Music]
onto the launch adapter before it was
viewed bringing its weight to just over
6 towns
[Music]
spacecraft was transferred to the final
Assembly Building and made it on top of
Aryan 5 some 35 meters above the ground
preparation team got their last glimpse
of the spacecraft as it was encapsulated
inside the fairing which has kept it
safe and sound until today
on Tuesday
Aryan 5 with juice on top
was rolled out to the Launchpad where
today it waits poised in anticipation
for its Ascent into the sky
foreign
so uh our passenger is sitting safe and
sound tucked under the fairing as you
can see waiting for liftoff in just over
two minutes but if I have moved to the
Sky Box overlooking the Jupiter control
room where as you can imagine everyone
is intensely focused on the last couple
of minutes to lift off and we can see
here as I was telling you uh the so the
the crowds that were sitting in Jupiter
control have now been asked to go out to
The Terraces on either side of the
control room they are among the like oh
so I didn't realize you could actually
see us we're sitting here in our Skybox
so they're out on The Terraces
um and they will be the lucky ones
who'll be able to see and also feel that
launch because trust me you feel it
uh what are we gonna see in the last few
seconds before liftoff uh Rafael well
everything is going to happen quite
quickly so like I said the electrical
power supply switch from ground to board
to cryogenic Arms which are feeding the
upper stage with fuel we see them
retract six seconds before liftoff the
broken engine will ignite first we need
to check it's working properly before we
switch on the boosters that's going to
happen seven seconds later so don't be
surprised if you don't see anything
during this seven seconds because
believe me you will see and you will
hear the launch
foreign
and you'll be hearing every Milestone
Stone being called out by the DDO he is
the range operations manager and his
role is in an oh we'll wait we'll wait
for the one minute Mark Rafael
um
right so from here on uh no more
commentary from us don't be surprised if
it doesn't take off immediately because
of course there are those seven seconds
I failed exactly just enjoy the launch
during which the Vulcan engines are set
on and then
enjoy
this is
foreign
we've seen the Ariane five
liftoff roaring through the Tropical Sky
carrying juice on the first leg of her
journey into space and now she has
disappeared under the crowds and see the
in crew there are many places from which
to uh to watch these launches as you can
see the beach any place and here we have
we have a glimpse again of
of the rocket Raphael it's an amazing
sensation for you as well I'm sure yeah
even with the clouds it's just that
projects
it's really really always impressive and
it's an emotion to to see it so the
video said that the trajectory is
nominal which means that it's working
perfectly in screen as planned
um
and in fact it just
a dozen in three words his
responsibility
as far he's the person who calls out
every Milestone along the way and he's
in charge of providing information on
propulsion guidance and trajectory
exactly he's like an orchestra
conjecture
Gathering all the informations and
summarizing it in real time and soon
we'll have booster separation
we're waiting for confirmation from the
DDO
is
so the boosters have been safely
separated this is great this is they
have
provided 90 of the overall thrusts of
the flight so they are doing the main
job and then soon we'll have the
separation of the Fairing and by the way
you see a special drawing on the fairing
right here
children's around the world were asked
to submit
inspired by Joseph's epic journey and on
this fairing we see one child's
interpretation of Jupiter embracing our
spacecrafts
everything is nominal
all parameters are coming smoothly and
there we have it we've seen it in our in
our three days and we've just heard it
from the DDO confirmed so the fairing
was used to protect the satellites from
the friction of the air
but also from the noise generated during
the ascent phase
we obviously need to safely separate the
fairing
um otherwise we would not be able to
release juice into space
it also means that we have crossed the
limit of the atmosphere so juice is on
its way to be separated in about 24
minutes from now
[Music]
cryogenic stage
when it has placed the launcher on an
intermediate orbits after this
I can mention that during and we can
actually see it on the motion design
because this is 3D animations here that
during the ascent phase the launcher is
set in what we call a barbecue mode so
it's slightly rotating on itself at a
speed of 0.7 degrees
so we do this so that every phase of the
satellite is equally exposed to the
sunlight we just want to avoid
overheating in one particular side of
the spacecraft which could damage the
instruments
and as a matter of fact when the upper
stage is going to be injected on the
targeted orbits
it will also rotate at a speed of 0.5
degrees in One Direction and then at the
same speed in the other direction
um again to avoid overeating on one part
of the spacecraft exactly like you know
a barbecue exactly and of course there
are the onboard computers what are they
measuring right now Rafael
well they optimized trajectory
everything is nominal so they optimize
the trajectory in real time they
minimize the proper end consumptions to
bring the launcher to the intermediate
orbit
targeted at the end of the main stage
proposition phase
and as a matter of fact we are
accelerating a lot right now
So within the next three to four minutes
we go from
when 3.5 kilometers per seconds to more
than seven kilometers per per second so
how much is that per hour because you're
the engineer 25 000 kilometers per hour
and ultimately Jews will be separated at
this project almost
10 kilometers per seconds
and it will be separated and at an
altitude of
1533 kilometers very precise okay so the
next Milestone we are now waiting for
and will be hearing this again from the
DDO is the acquisition by our downrange
station of natal that is located in the
on an island in the middle of the
Atlantic Alistair
wait and hear that from the DDO
he may not have confirmed it orally but
that but by now just to explain all
along the Route is towards iron is
tracked from the ground
so the launchers functions and vital
signs are recorded and sent back to a
network of stations that keeps constant
watch on the health
of the launcher systems
apologies of course I did not mean
Ascension I meant natal over the Border
in Brazil of course that's the second
downwind station and just so you know in
all that's about
1 500 parameters that is collected
collected my goodness so that there's no
way these
can be analyzed in real time Raphael
what happens to them well the complete
analysis is carried out in the weeks
following the launch
by a dedicated team they provide a
wealth of information about how the
vehicle performed
during its Mission
um and so this is why we constantly well
improve our knowledge of a launcher
launch after launch and then that's why
rn5 is such a reliable launcher and so
you're talking about the uh the stations
and it's a little bit you were saying to
me earlier when we were chatting it's
like a week
yeah you were listening to the video
what did he say I didn't hear he said
that all the parameters are working
perfectly no no the flight is perfectly
smooth so yeah this is like a relay race
with one Telemetry station passing the
bottom to the next one because we want
to keep full visibility of the launcher
in all Dynamic phases of the flight so
the first edition is to pick up the data
was galio right here in crew followed by
natal and Brazil then the island of the
island of Ascension in the middle of the
Atlantic and followed by liberville in
Gabor and finally malindi in Kenya as
the launcher crosses
so we'll have
three different very short sequence
right now coming up the cutoff of the
main stage we should hear that the main
stage and then the ignition of the upper
stage so it should be confirmed
extensions
PC
and the ignition coming up
that's a very good news that's uh very
important
you can't because we're in our little
booth because we forgot to mention that
we are now in the sky Booth uh where we
have a fantastic view over Jupiter where
we can see the crowds gathered and uh
yes and so you cannot see the smile on
Raphael's face but he is delighted that
this stage has gone perfectly yeah the
in addition of upper stage is absolutely
because it's always quite a little bit
tricky to ignite a liquid stage in The
Emptiness of states of space Sorry I
told you that on the ground we wait for
a few seconds to check that the Vulcan
engine is correctly ignited
before liftoff but it's space it's just
not possible to do that you cannot send
somebody to repair the the engine also
in zero gravity the propellant is
floating in order
the thermal environment is also not the
same as it is on the ground so you know
there are many factors that make it
complex to enact the engine in space
so uh we were mentioning earlier this is
the penultimate Arian 5 launch which for
more than a quarter of a century has
provided Europe with reliable and
independent access to space which Joseph
was talking about earlier our n6 will be
taking over Europe's best Engineers are
building on the success of Aryan 5 and
there's already a fully integrated Aryan
6 on the launch pad right here in Kuru
you're going to tell us about that
Raphael so can you take us through the
latest developments with rn6
so last last year was quite exciting for
rncs with the start of the what we call
the combined test corresponding to the
meeting between the launcher and the
Launchpad here
we see a fully representative version of
rn6 which has been assembled with the
main core raised vertically directed on
the LaunchPad
the upper composite was then hosted and
mated on top of the launcher
this operational scheme is actually a
big difference with respect to what is
done with rn5 it is made possible thanks
to this mobile Gumtree which will
obviously be removed during launch
and also to 2023 is going to be here so
busier for Ireland 6 obviously in
January the launcher was connected to
the control bench and the first Power
test was performed
then dry run will be performed followed
by the actual Fielding operations of the
central project
teams will also perform hot firing tests
of the lower stage engine Wilkin 2.1
including a long firing test and hard
firing test of the upper Stitch were
successfully performed in 2022 and
beginning of 2023 in Olympus housing at
the German Aerospace Center preparation
so launcher elements that will be used
for the iron 6 First Flight will arrive
in front of Guyana using the new
generation canopy vessel which will be
equipped with sales and hybrid
properties
so that we can start the first real
launch campaign of iron 6 and so today
the Prototype of Aryans 5 are in six
sorry stands on the launch pad ready to
continue the combined test so good luck
for this very ambitious and incredible
program
and Raphael um we had while you were
explaining all of this we heard that the
video called up loss of signal with the
natal tracking station
there we go and didn't we didn't hear
that they didn't been picked up by the
next station is that normal it is
perfectly normal to have short
visibility holes during non-dynamic
phases of the launch
in this case we have no visibility for
just 63 seconds before the Ascension
ground station speaks the signal back so
this should come in any seconds
your timing is perfect confirmed
so we've been picked up by by the next
downwind station that is a Ascension the
tiny little island
so from what I understand uh we're going
back to our n6 there's a very healthy
order book already for Ariane 6 launches
Rafael yeah rn6 is already quite
successful on the market with already 28
launchers sold for both institutions and
Commercial customers it is a very
versatile flexible launcher perfectly
suited for complex missions and
satellite constellations deployment
thanks to its High Lifter capability and
its reignitable upper stage engine
it's nice to it's nice to hear the
regular updates from the DDO that
everything is going to plan for those of
you who are joining us Aryan 5 lifted
sorry lifted off
14 minutes ago just over 40 minutes ago
from the European Spaceport here in
French Guyana carrying issa's Jupiter
icy moons Explorer into outer space
we're bringing you this live show from
the Jupiter control room where the
operational teams are overseeing the
missions progress juice is due to
separate in about 13 minutes time but
this is just the start of its long
journey on its way to Jupiter let's find
out more about the tech on board that
will help it fulfill its mission
record
this Mission led by Essa is a giant
bird-like spacecraft with large solar
panel Wings stretching out on either
side of its main body
with a mass of 6100 kilos at launch
juice is a heavy spacecraft carrying 10
high Precision Instruments including the
most powerful remote sensing geophysical
and in-situ payloads ever flown to the
outer solar system building a spacecraft
though which has to fly around Jupiter
is a challenge to operate a spacecraft
you need energy we need power and
normally we get power from the Sun
there is not much sun therefore the
Solar Ray has to be very big there is
also another challenge all the stuff
that we built there has to survive very
low temperature and the third one is
that the environment around Jupiter is
very radioactive that's why I think the
solar array which is very exposed and
put together these three difficult
technology is really a great piece of
engineering
maybe a piece of art
the instruments were contributed by the
juice Mission scientific partner the
spacecraft was developed and built by
Airbus an Aryan group savoir Fair
equipped juice with the chemical
propulsion system that will drive it to
Jupiter and its icy moons on an
eight-year Cruise
we will provide the proportion system
for juice which ensure that after
leaving the launcher it arrived
correctly at Jupiter's moon and can work
properly there
it's a fascinating thing especially
because the technical requirements of
such a long journey with so many
constraints to consider challenge each
of us in a unique way foreign
Engineers have devised Advanced
technological solutions so that juice
can operate in extreme environments face
Jupiter's High radiation belt the long
distance and harsh temperatures it's two
and a half meter diameter antenna we'll
send the data juice collects back to
Mission Control although it can take
close to an hour to travel to earth
in Mission juice is going to be a real
Revolution
collection of valuable data will be used
by scientists for years to come and help
unlock some of the greatest Mysteries of
the universe
so Raphael juice is an emblematic
European science Mission so what is it
about this particular mission that
inspires you as a rocket scientist
well dream and dream has always been a
very strong driving
for me but also for I think everybody
who works in the space industry the if
we go on a more personal note actually
before working at iron space many years
ago already in my life as a space writer
I remember that one of my first real
article I wrote was about Jupiter's icy
moon and the preparation of the Jews
Mission with a focus on the moon Europa
and you can imagine that I would have
never thought back then that I would be
here standing in Kuru Spaceport in the
Jupiter room to come out
on its deployment into space and I think
I'm not mistaken when I say that all my
colleagues I are inspired by such
emblematic Mission it really gave us an
extra boost each time and especially
when it comes to a mission aimed at
looking for signs of life that is just
something else it's difficult to
actually fathom okay can you I mean yeah
the ambition of Jews and it's a very
complex Mission by the way so
everything is Monument is nominal but
thinking that
one probe is going to be around the
moons of Jupiter which are and explored
words with oceans of liquid water under
the eye surface
where
where exoper energies expect to find
some forms of life we don't know like
microbes maybe shrimps maybe some small
fish probably not but let's dream and
especially on the moon of Europa it's
just absolutely incredible
indeed Raphael hundreds of Professionals
in Europe are working on this crucial
Mission we met some of them earlier and
as we know it takes a whole family to
put such an expedition together so let's
hear from some of the partners of this
mission
my name is rossella and I originally
come from Italy my name is
German rocket engineer working for Aryan
group in Bremen I'm Italian and I'm a
telecommunication engineer
Madrid is
[Music]
foreign
tests so all the final checks after the
transport of the satellites here in Kuru
and before the launch I'm responsible
for the follow-up of the stage
integration up to the launch the
treatment of technical anomalies with an
end to NGO the technical consistency of
all information and the on-site presence
include during launch campaign
is
I take care of the assembly and
integration of all the units of the
spacecraft and afterwards to make sure
that the test campaign goes as planned
and that the spacecraft will perform as
expected Once In Space if I want to
define the team spirit in three keywords
I can say the first one is collaboration
the second keyword is coordination and
then the third keyword which is the most
important for me is to have fun it helps
overcoming difficulties and and
obstacles so yeah for me this is the
most important part
foreign
coming up to 22 minutes after liftoff
which means that in just over five
minutes juice will be separating from
the mothership and starting its own life
in space Raphael can you give us an
update on where we're at right now so
everything is working perfect
so we have the man in the Telemetry
station acquisition so in the past five
minutes we went from
190 kilometers to more than 500
kilometers of altitude so it now has a
speed of
9.6 kilometer per seconds which is
absolutely gigantic it is almost
into space
during the next five minutes we'll
increase altitude even faster we'll gain
an additional 1 000 kilometer in
altitude and by the way the weight of
our structure right now is 14 tons about
only two percent of the initial mass of
the rn5 when it was on the ground that
is just unbelievable two percent
Ariane 5 typically launches
geostationary transfer orbit launches so
here we're sending Jews obviously much
much farther on the Escape orbit how is
this different how does it differ for
example
well the energy to provide to the
spacecraft by the launcher is higher it
needs to escape the gravitational pull
of the earth also for geostationary
launches we usually have
30 minutes to one hour and a half let's
say during which we can try and launch
and today's mission is sort of a
rendezvous mission
and there was no launch window
it was it was what we call an instant
launch so we had to launch an exact time
so this is why everything has to go
smoothly even the weather before
launching also a dual launches to the
geostationary orbit usually happen in
the evening
today we launched in the morning meaning
that the team have been working all
night during The Final Countdown
and also we had to slightly adapt the
feeling of the upper stage cryogenic
propellant as the launcher was exposed
to the sun since early morning 6 a.m so
the Sun hits and increases the pressure
of the tanks so we had to slightly
underload it by 120 tons
so how is it that this mission in itself
different in terms of preparation
well we need to take Extra Care in terms
of cleanliness because before before
leaving the Earth we want to know
exactly what kind of biological material
juice takes with it in a French Guiana
there were several institutes which took
samples from Jews in the various
satellite preparation rooms
of course most of the microbes will be
sterilized in space
he
here we see
on the image his majesty the king of
Belgian and his Royal Highness Prince
Gabrielle
who and they they are here as a VIP
guests because Belgium has contributed
uh rather um uh importantly towards uh
um so we were talking about we were
looking at the the uh the difference in
preparation weren't we the second main
difference is that you know Jews will
perform very precise magnetic field
measurements around Ganymede the moon of
Jupiter and we had to measure many times
the magnetic environment of juice during
the launch campaign on the ground to
make sure that in space it will measure
only
the magnetic environment of ganymed and
not its own magnetic field because it
has a very very strong magnetic field of
course exactly
um okay and so uh in a nutshell looking
at the time oh
we actually have her I haven't heard it
from the DDO did you
so right now we are in the stage where
the upper stage is performing slight
orientation maneuvers to separate the
spacecraft in a very specific Direction
it's important to do so on time in a
very precise way as it will really drive
the satellite injection accuracy and
have an impact on the rest after
spacecraft's lifetime in space just to
give you
the juice
trajectory correction maneuver
and so the better the injection
Precision the less important the
maneuver is going to be
meaning that Jews will be able to save
its pressure fuel for the rest of the
mission
and Raphael we are 30 seconds away from
separation what we're going to see
exactly and then we'll
stop the commentary and wait for the
moment
let me remind you that this is 3D
animation here between the teams are
receiving signals and information in
real time and it is them who will
confirm the separation of juice on its
Liberation orbit
they will provide all necessary
information to either teams
so that they can inquire
the spacecraft
let's wait for confirmation from the
video
this has been confirmed that this
spacecraft is safely separated
on its targeted orbit
and you can see on the images
the relief from the teammates this is
years and years of work on the part of
these teams Decades of works for some
yes and it is it is so good to see such
Joy on their faces a reminder that this
is the very very first leg of juices
Journey
you can see the emotions on the faces
that's really what makes space
activities so special it's like a
reboost each time we launch a satellite
and what a satellite right now honestly
I can only wish good luck to choose and
all the teams for this Incredible
Journey tour through the outer solar
system that's absolutely amazing what we
are living right now the atmosphere here
in Jupiter is effervescent
there is a true sense of joy and
happiness but as I was I was saying of
course this is a the very beginning of
the journey and uh we will be letting of
course the teams in darmstadt take over
shortly because they are the ones who
are going to be confirming acquisition
of signals First Signs of Life from our
passenger you're going to say Raphael
now I was saying to say yeah this is the
beginning of the journey for Jews for
the launcher we may perform what we call
so a passivation of the upper stage
meaning that the remaining proponent of
the tanks is expected in order to
prevent
any risk of explosion in space you see
the requirement for a sustainable use of
space and we also perform a very small
disposal maneuver in order to remove the
air Prestige from any operational orbit
giving an extra push of 13 meters per
second
and so yes and then this is going to be
the real end of the mission for uh the
launcher but right now let's focus on
the Joy on people's face this is
absolutely incredible juice is on its
way to Jupiter
and it
literally um especially a joy when when
you know considering the stress that a
delay brings even though we know that
the passenger is safe it is it is a lot
of work for many many people to have to
yeah delay and and a very safe a choice
to make of course as we can see today so
again in a few minutes
is our teams
we acquire
the satellites we're now waiting for uh
of course for comments from Stefan
Israel who's just been miked up in the
Fishbowl and he'll be with us very
shortly so uh
we'll we'll of course tell you when he's
with us we'll let you know and we'll let
you enjoy the smiles and happiness on
everyone's face
hello
and here we have Stefan who is marked up
and ready Stefan Israel over to you
a few seconds delay but he's with us
over to you Stefan
so today mission is a full success team
Europe has perfectly delivered I really
want to pay our tribute to all the teams
who have made the success possible iron
space and iron good team for sure all
the supply chain
Isa or customer for and urban defense
and space who is the juice manufacturer
it's really the success of Team Europe
today with the support as well for sure
of course here on the Spaceport and with
the design authority of iron5 it is a
absolutely perfect launch tonight today
and it is now the start of a journey for
Jews ATL's Journey
thank you very much Stefan Israel
are in space CEO so we our teams are now
going to uh at esoc are now going to be
taking over from here so we're going to
hand over to them in in Mission Control
Esa Mission Control in darmstadt over to
you Matt
ah thank you very much Lisa so welcome
back to everyone uh we are standing in
the heart of the European space
operations center esoc a facility in
darmstadt and this is the mission
control room right behind me the main
one uh we've got a couple of major
Milestone events coming up in less than
five minutes we hope to get the first
acquisition of signal that's where we
actually talk to the spacecraft itself
and that gets picked up by an Issa
ground station there'll be an icon on
the screen that signifies that and
that's a huge satellite dish and in
about an hour we should then have the
final and next key Milestone which is
the deployment of juices enormous solar
panels so I'm going to be talking to
loads of mission scientists and
Engineers on this Mission and if you're
watching and have questions then you can
ask them you can go on social media and
go to hashtag ask Issa and we will pick
them up and I'll try and get those
questions answered uh I'm super super
lucky and we're all really super excited
as well this has been an amazing day
after yesterday's disappointment for the
next half hour I've got Deputy flight
director Bruno Souza who's standing
there in the heart of the operation so
Bruno how is it looking there in the
nerve center right now well it's what a
beautiful flight what a beautiful flight
from Marianne five everybody's quite
excited but now starts the hard part the
next major critical Milestone we have is
called acquisition of signal we will
expect to hear from the spacecraft from
our ground station at new Yorkshire in
Australia if you see behind me there is
a
plot over there on the screen if this
was a hospital and the satellite was our
patient that would be the
electrocardiogram and what we want to
see there is a nice beautiful shape
should resemble the Himalayas with a
half rest in the middle that indicates
the satellite is alive and healthy if we
only see the Kilimanjaro we'll have some
work to do if we don't see anything at
all we'll just have to be patient and
wait for it to come it will come for
sure so now starts the hard part the
teams will start working pay attention
to the acquisition of signal coming up
at any minute
so so much has happened already as you
can see on the bottom of your screen
with four icons representing major
milestones in the launch today we've
made it through the first two which is
unbelievably exciting uh launch and
separation of juice well done to those
teams the next one you can see is the
ground station big satellite dish which
is our acquisition of signal icon and
the solar array deployment icon is that
final one as you can see I've got a new
uh guest here so the first of our guests
are Angela Dietz so I've been watching
you uh working in the control room so
you've come off a night shift is that
right not yet we started at six o'clock
in the morning that's okay
the second time we did it um and
everything worked well and yes we
launched it's amazing and in about a
minute we actually might see the
acquisition of signal already so it
might be already coming up now it's not
guaranteed there could be also delays if
the spacecraft has a certain spin from
the separation from the launcher
explain explaining a bit like a mountain
in the middle
um yeah so this is the frequency band
the current station is listening too so
it's pointed at
um at juice where juice is supposed to
be and um
yeah the communication system on the
spacecraft was already started so it's
already transmitting data but here we
wait for the spacecraft actually to come
over the horizon so to really to arrive
to be seen from from the corn station so
so we've got a we've got a small window
where we can see this or you know how
big is the window where we can actually
see this actually well the first time
would be actually now
but it could be delayed up to 40 minutes
so really depends how the spacecraft is
moving it's a little bit tumbling it's
this the spacecraft will first do an
acquisition yeah
um and and stabilize the attitude okay
right we're just coming up to this
acquisition window so I'm gonna go over
to Bruno in the control room and see if
we can see what's happening
we just have to be patient the signal is
not there yet at any moment now it will
appear actually I will not bother you
describing it too much just stay with me
and watch that signal until it pops up
with the signal of our spacecraft
Odom
or Modi quick brief from lenosha they
see the darling for Marianne
so it's about seconds or minutes that we
will see just
it's
copy that
stand by
got it
no signal yet
foreign
we still don't have acquisition of
signal at this point
um this satellite as you might have
heard already has been separated from
the from the launcher from Ariane 5. as
it separates there's always a certain
rotation a tumbling effect the satellite
needs to First Prime the thrusters that
means it needs to make all the pipes
open such that the the fuel and the
oxidizer can flow through it at this
point it can use the thrusters for
control and then it will try to find its
own orientation in space and at that
point it will switch on the transmitter
and start transmitting so there's always
a certain uncertainty about the time
when we'll actually receive the signal
we have to be patient we have to keep
looking and I'm sure it will wake up
quite soon
so thanks very much Bruno so uh Angela
um what does it mean what does this
actually mean how long do we have to
kind of try and get this signal Acquired
and you know where where are we what's
uh what's your feelings right now
for me this is I'm still nominal yeah
still quite nominal
um so it's really
um what what we said like 51 that the
spacecraft comes over
um The Horizon of the antenna so it
could be seen from the antenna but that
doesn't mean the spacecraft is already
in the states to really transmit uh it's
what porno was said so it's really uh
still finding uh stabilizing the
attitude
um so yeah only in about half an hour we
start we would start to get nervous so
from this point we're still normal for
our point of view and if it is tumbling
and the the spacecraft itself does its
own kind of trying to work itself out
and that obviously there's millions of
different scenarios I'm assuming of how
it does that so is that why there might
be this delay in terms of how it how it
works it so far yeah there's some some
studies some investigations that we've
done how much the tumbling could be and
yeah it could be yeah worst case yeah
just taking this time okay well thanks
very much uh yeah so um thanks very much
for joining us it's uh it's really tense
now it's super tense so if you've just
joined us and you are following the
juice spacecraft after its separation
from Ariane 5 we're hoping to actually
talk to the spacecraft soon uh it's
starting its billion kilometer journey
to Jupiter uh uh and well many billion a
kilometer journey to duty we're in the
European space operations center where
the fleet of the European satellites are
and spacecraft are actually flown and
controlled by a large multinational team
people and Gala uh scientists and
Engineers if you want to ask questions
of my many guests that are coming up you
can use the hashtag ask Esa and I'll try
and get them answered as as soon as I
can but in the meantime I'm going to
switch you back over to Bruno
to me
oh for the who's who in the main control
yeah tell us who in this in the who all
this international team are
just as well it's a good opportunity to
introduce everybody who's into the
control room right now and I will start
with this side of the room
and this function are the software
coordinators tonight today Marta and
Luca and Danielle are taking care of all
our software so all the software that is
running on these consoles and on the
servers
it's taken care by them if anything
fails they bring it back up
right next to them are the ground
operations managers and they are taking
care of all the facilities all the
ground stations making sure that we are
connected to the ground station
configuring the ground station to
listening on the satellite so they will
be responsible for finding the satellite
in the sky shortly Now we move over here
to the flight control team
and in the flight control team they're
responsible for operating the satellite
so they will Take Over Control once we
see it in the sky different functions
are present here on the front row
platform is responsible for our radio
communication system and for our thermal
system
Rudy is on shift at the moment right
next to him our tour is taking care of
the data handling that's our onboard
computer our Mass memory and all the
routing of data to the ground is taken
care by actor and then over here on this
side we have the attitude and Orbit
Control
experts in this case Julio today he's
taking care
of monitoring the separation sequence
and what's happening on board is also a
system engineer and leading all these
people
at the moment is my dear friend and
colleague for many years Ignacio tanko
who I may add is probably one of the
best spacecraft operations managers in
the world right now
at least the only one flying to Jupiter
today
and over here on the on the last row
we have the flight director he's also on
this side of the ocean orchestrating
like a maestro all the teams that are
now
working towards a successful mission for
Jews
and next to him we have project support
project representative they have been
working on the development of Jews for
many years
and they have been managing the program
and now they're finally seeing the the
fruit of their long years of work and
they also our interface to the Airbus
team that built a satellite and they're
sitting in a room behind this wall
providing us all the support that we
need
back to you Matt
thanks very much Bruno right uh always
absolutely amazing to have Bruno's
expertise on the floor and just all
those amazing people what an absolutely
awesome team they are so if you've just
joined us we're live in Germany here in
the heart of the control center where
the European Fleet of satellites and
spacecraft are indeed flown as we've
just seen uh you can join in at home and
send in your questions at hashtag ask
Esa so right now we're trying to talk to
the spacecraft and that is done with a
ground station uh called nor new norsha
which is actually in Australia and I'm
amazingly we're going to be able to
speak to the manager of new nausea suji
Jackson all the way the other side of
the world we've got to go right the way
through the world to get there so yeah
let's go there right now
hello Susie so right behind you I can
see an enormous dish that looks very
much like our acquisition of signal icon
is that the one that we're actually
going to be using to try and talk to the
juice spacecraft
yes so this is universio one this is our
35 meter main antenna here at new
Yorkshire and we're currently um having
a go at acquiring uh juice as we speak
as you can see we're up a little ways
away from the Horizon already so uh the
spacecraft is up in the sky here
conditions here are really good uh
really nominal and we're waiting for the
signal to come in from the spacecraft so
that does look like an enormous dish is
does that track it straight away or is
there another dish that sort of can move
faster and get a track a hold of the
spacecraft before this massive enormous
dish does
yeah so for these uh early Acquisitions
of spacecraft that are still close to
the close to the uh close to the Earth
we cheat a little bit because because
we've got such a big dish here with
universal one it has a very very very
narrow beam so it's only able to spot
spot a spacecraft in a very small very
well-defined area because we are
completely sure where where uh juice is
yet there might be a little bit of
variation in its in its trajectory
although I hear everything's nominal so
far we use a smaller antenna which is up
behind me on the hill called new
Yorkshire 2 and that's a four and a half
meter antenna and it has a beam width
that's uh close to 10 times as big so
it's about half a degree so if the if
juice is up there and it's transmitting
to us we'll see it so as soon as juice
gets its gets its act together and gets
its attitude stabilized and starts
talking to us we'll um definitely hear
that signal yeah juice is keeping us all
guessing at the moment so how long can
the how long can this dish actually
track juice for is it for the whole day
or you know how does that work
okay
yeah so our nominal mission tonight will
be about uh seven hours from AOS right
the way through to what we call Los loss
of signal so we'll track up into the sky
up to about 50 degrees and then uh while
we're doing that uh juice is moving away
from the planet and the planets Revolt
rotating underneath juice so it'll
actually come up and rather than going
over the other side like like a normal a
normal satellite that's in Earth's orbit
would do it'll actually go up and then
come back down as the spacecraft moves
away and as the Earth rotates underneath
so we'll see in if you're still watching
in seven hours which I'm sure you won't
we'll see the antenna set again uh
pretty much back where we came from let
me let me let me let me yes Susie I've
got some great news for you we have
acquisition of signal so I'm going to go
over to Bruno in the main control room
this is super Ace news whoa whoa what
can I say these are the words that every
spacecraft operations engineer wants to
hear and Andrea comatsu just said them
to us he said we have a position of
signal the spacecraft is transmitting
Telemetry it's flowing into our systems
everybody's super excited super happy
uh well it's a lot of work from now
onwards and we have to keep on going
so we'll keep reporting back how we're
doing first of all we've reached a
fantastic Milestone the spacecraft is
alive you start seeing Mount Everest
popping up there in the in the plot
right now
the Telemetry is Flowing a nominal we
will now start checking every subsystem
to make sure that everything is healthy
after this crazy ride into space and
then we'll report back to tell you how
we're doing
back to you Matt thanks so much Bruno I
mean this is I think it's actually made
it more exciting yes now don't forget
you can get involved at home and ask
questions and we are on a roller coaster
so we've just hit our first of our
Milestones we've got one more really big
one coming up so if you fancy joining in
asking questions then please do send in
your uh in in your facts so I'm going to
be joined in uh in a second after I show
you a video about how exciting this
whole journey has been for mankind uh
getting getting here to send a
spacecraft after Jupiter and so we're
going to play you a little video now uh
and I'm going to take you back in time
we're going to go back far back in time
[Music]
thank you
ah so I've got my newest guest I'm
joined by Anna Xena Solomon you do the
senior scientist at the Hellenic Space
Center who's been working on juice uh uh
welcome to the show thank you so uh we
just saw a video that went back to the
moment where Galileo um
saw Jupiter with his own eyeballs I mean
this is this is incredible so uh tell us
why Jupiter is just so fascinating
well Jupiter has countless fascinating
facts there's so many things to tell
about Jupiter right first of all it's
the largest planet of our solar system
it's really massive it's similar to a
star but it never got big enough in
order to start burning
so compared to Earth it's more than 300
times more massive than Earth is pretty
big and in fact it's actually 2.5 times
more massive than any other planet of
our solar system combined so that's
about size right then it has very big
storms like the red giant spot that we
have on uh on Jupiter that it's been
there for hundreds of years and it also
it's covered also with clouds that they
go they're like 50 kilometers thick so
you can imagine about the the size right
and what we're talking about it also has
rings we don't know that much you know
but uh Jupiter's Rings compared to what
we know about Saturn for instance but
they're there it's just they're a little
bit fainter yeah
um it also it has been observed but
eight different spacecrafts throughout
the time and of course it has the most
moons than any other planet of our solar
system so we count 95 months up to today
and some of them the Galilean moons are
so interesting and so important that
we're sending a mission to go there and
look at them you know a dedicated one
we've had this picture up on the screen
is is this is this the sort of thing
that Galileo might have seen through his
telescope well I can imagine that he
didn't see that precisely it was
something fainter and more blurry uh but
you know he saw something so that was
very important yeah so when he first
looked at when he first looked at
Jupiter did he actually see the moons
when he first saw it or did he have to
sort of adapt his Optics and get better
actually being a telescope maker exactly
yeah so while Jupiter was known since
the ancient times Galileo was the first
one in 6010 that made a detailed
observation of the planet and because he
made some improvements to his small
telescope he was able to observe more
distinctly some bodies and that's how he
was able to observe the Galilean
satellite so we're talking about
Ayo Europa Ganymede and Kalisto so yeah
and in a sense
um Jupiter is gonna try to do the same
if we think about it so Galileo improved
his uh small telescope his main
instrument and he was able to see
something that wasn't seen before so now
now with Jews we're going back with
state of the art new and unique
instruments to improve what we've seen
before with previous missions so in a
sense Jews is going to significantly
um enhance our knowledge and push
further the capabilities of previous
missions and previous observations so
yeah these Galilean moons as you said is
so synonymous with um with Jupiter
um the actual Mission itself has
actually got a a tribute to the man
himself Galileo so do you know can you
tell us just a little bit about about
that tribute yeah there's a plug that is
mounted on the spacecraft and it's it
actually replicates a few pages from I
think we have a little bit of a screen
here of it yeah exactly yeah so you see
this being mounted on the spacecraft and
it replicates a few images from Galileo
book where he described the observations
of the moons back in 1610
so I think it's very emotional and it's
a very nice touch to bring something
from Earth to this you know outer solar
system body yeah and say okay we've been
following you for so many years yeah
it's beautiful I'm just going to remind
listeners that they can ask questions of
my guest you just have to
find social media and and just use the
hashtag ask Issa we're actually in
darmstadt in Germany which is where they
fly and look after all these amazing
spacecraft the European Space Agency
build and I'm here with scientists
engineers and spacecraft Specialists
it's a real special moment to talk to
these people um what is one of Europe's
biggest missions ever this journey to uh
juice
ah I'm gonna I'm gonna hand over to
Bruno because he has some news for us
let's go
more good news the spacecraft is in a
hurry we acquired a signal and we just
realized that the spacecraft is going
quite fast through the configuration
into the automatic sequence that is
leading us towards the Solar Ray
deployment so in fact the last
pyroteactics that will release the solar
rays will fire in about 15 minutes and
at that point we might start seeing the
solar rays then deploying and reaching
their final position so all in all we
should count on about 20 minutes until
we have the solar rays fully deployed
thanks so much Bruno that is like
amazing news we've gone from being
scared to being uh joyous here so um
I've uh someone's actually sent in a
question from Twitter and it says here a
question from my daughter why are you
going there hmm
that's the key question I think we're
going there because we want to go you
know we're gonna be close and personal
with the habitable words of our solar
system and we have amazing examples
there we're talking about Ganymede
Europa and Kalisto so we go in there we
have because we we have some fundamental
questions to answer and these are coming
from the previous missions and some of
them is very simple
how do these moons look like in detail
we're going to spend some time there so
we will have the opportunity to look
closely and overlap you know go back to
the previous to places that we visited
before and see how do they change with
time we want to see also we want to
examine explore a gas a typical gas
giant like Jupiter you know this is an
amazing opportunity and we want to see
how this complex environment formed and
shaped all these moons so we have pretty
good reasons to go back and specifically
if we think about the moons we we're
going back we're going to look very
closely at Ganymede and Ganymede is the
largest satellite of our solar system it
has its own magnetic field that doesn't
happen with other satellites and it's a
very good example of a liquid
environment let's not forget that the
most interesting fact about this moons
is that they're all worlds and what does
that mean is that they hide a liquid
ocean underneath their icy surface so
Ganymede is a very good example of a
liquid environment trapped in between
icy layers then we're going to Europa
and Europa is 4.5 billion years old but
the surface is only 20 to 180 million
years old it's very very young and it
also we suspect that the water there is
in Europa is double the the water we
have here on Earth
so it's the best candidate if you want
to find life out of Earth Europa is a
very good candidate to go and you know
search and look around well I mean
that's that's why we're going isn't it
the water thinks thanks so much for
joining us I mean yeah yeah the whole
the whole purpose of going to Jupiter is
just blowing my mind but thank you so
much so we've just got to the hour mark
after launch I think it's about time we
went back to Bruno and got a more of an
update what's happening in the control
room Bruno
it's all going according to plan uh the
the pyros are firing in sequence every
time one fires we wait another two
minutes the next one fires we will get
an information as soon as we reach the
last ones and then we will know that we
are just a few minutes away from full
array deployment
so we just have to hang on a few minutes
more everything is is going super smooth
all subsystems have reported already
that the spacecraft looks quite healthy
so no reason to worry at this point
let's just keep watching a few minutes
more and we should have also power being
produced by the spacecraft itself
so much Bruno so sending a spacecraft to
Jupiter really is no mean feat with some
very hard obstacles to overcome I'm I'm
delighted that I'm joined by Frederick
Fay from Airbus who are the main
contractor that actually built the
actual spacecraft itself so welcome
Frederick
um so uh what are the challenges for the
spacecraft of you know it's a super
harsh environment isn't it space and so
what are the challenges that it faces on
this 12-year timeline in fact we're
looking at this timeline here can you
describe a little bit about about the
Journey about the what what how the
actual Journey works and yes so in fact
the mission was defined to maximize the
mass of science instrument to be brought
to Jupiter and to do that Aryan 5 was
not powerful enough to send directly the
spacecraft
Maps would have been too small and the
what has been designed by uh Mission
analysis team and then tuned by a flight
Dynamics Team is multi people fly by to
benefit from Gravity assist over
a massive planet
on the way to Jupiter and as a result we
have one year after launch we'll have a
lunar Earth flyby which will first
accelerate the spacecraft in fact send
it to our Venus when you're after then
accelerate again accelerate again around
the Earth
the third acceleration of the trans
years and then a 2.5
leg to Jupiter and it was within the
mission capability to be able to
rejupiter within 10 years it was a
requirement for the mission analysis and
each year you can find depending of the
configuration of the planet you can find
some trajectory with the Venus Anders
with Venus Earth and Mars on the
different combination I mean in fact the
combination that we have today for this
one window is a Earth's Venus Earth
Earth and the N Jupiter with some
peculiarity on the first one to have an
even more effective script at the
beginning of the mission
missionaries guy and found a possibility
to use linear and Earth in one day
separation so first you add 700
kilometer just around the moon and then
you are one day after around the earth
and you have a double acceleration that
improves the overall energetical
scenario
Xena Jupiter will have a full tour with
three Moon explored so Kalisto again
made on Europe Two Times Europe and this
is done through 35 other flyby so this
flyby are both scientific but also used
to shape the orbit and progressively to
go toward an orbit that will enable us
to orbit our own Ganymede that will be
also very first in spacecraft mechanics
yeah so there's a few first there I've
not seen a lunar Earth fly by is that is
that the first time that's been done by
a tomato ages yeah I'm not saying that
before so and the other interesting
thing is we're going in completely the
wrong direction I don't know if you know
this but Venus seems to be right towards
the sun yeah if you notice it's closer
to the center but when you see
um so it's very effective interval
entire gravity assist it's more
effective than marks that is in between
Earth and Jupiter but combining all
those planets at the end allows a good
trip yeah it's interesting isn't it that
even in six years time she's still going
to be flying around the earth yeah and
it's yeah that's it's incredible isn't
it so on this journey we've got really
extreme temperatures haven't we we've
got like I'm assuming by Venus it gets
incredibly hot and out by Jupiter
there's nothing this is one of the
difficulty of the mission to benefit
from this Venus Fly by it means also
that we have to face a solar flux will
be very high about two two times the
flux receiver now so about three
kilowatt per square meter we go even
closer to the central Venus so and at
the Jupiter we have had a very low uh
certain elimination so the range of sun
elimination is from 1 to 60 meaning that
the spacecraft has to cope with very hot
and very cold temperature case
uh in the variate case some areas of the
spacecraft will be at plus 250 degrees C
which is so we need some specific
material and when we are rgbt there in
particular at the end of the Jupiter
Eclipse which can last up to five hours
then the temperature of the coldest part
of the spacecraft which is the solar eye
drop down to minus 230 degrees C so you
have to design a spacecraft that cope
with more or less 500 degree of
Excursion in temperature yeah so it's
have what Solutions you've actually
developed to do that so it's multiple
solution for the body of the spacecraft
it's a first isolating the spacecraft
from the Sun so it's by multi-layer
covers thermal covers we have up to 25
layer which protects the spacecraft when
we are close to the Sun going to Venus
we also Point again antenna towards the
sun which is used as the first e-shield
diameter
we tilt them to minimize the surface
presented to the cell and this is this
tilt is maintained when we are in in
between the Earth and the Sun and then a
Jupiter we have to to benefit from also
from the multi-layer insulation that
enable to maintain the electronic inside
the spacecraft within let's say a
comfortable environment with a minimum
of eater power that is also provided by
your electrical heaters uh yeah I've got
some questions coming in from social
media they'll ask you in a second I've
just got one question that I'd I've been
the radiation that we're getting at um
radiation and Jupiter what what what are
the different sources of radiation and
how are they affecting the spacecraft
Jupiter is a big system in fact and
Jupiter is very massive and it creates
some tidal effect on the closest
which is IO and IO is not icy moon it's
a volcanic moon this volcanism is
created by Jupiter gravity and as a
result of that you have a large ejection
of i o material basically social dioxide
that is then catched by the magnetic
field of Jupiter magnetic field Jupiter
is huge so ejections are done at several
hundred of kilometers above the surface
overview captured by the magnetic field
which is rotating fastest than the moon
itself on and its orbit and then it is
ionized and transformed into ions and
electrons on the protons but the
electrons are further accelerated and
become the very high energy electron
much more than what we can face on the
earth and these are ridiculous
Electronics
adjust what I really want to get this
someone's asked a question out on the on
the hashtag ask Esa Channel and they're
they're debating in the office will this
be the heaviest interplanetary
spacecraft ever launched
no no because your spacecraft is going
even faster
uh via Joe I think it goes faster no no
heaviest
it's just a 16 for interpreter yes it is
heaviest and the six turns are made of
2.2 ton of dry mass and more than 3.6
ton of um problem mass and let's see 200
kilo or 220 kilo of increment so for 220
kilo of real silence increment you need
a six turn for this Mission yeah at
lunch it's a it's a long journey isn't
it how much fuel do you need inside the
field is not really for the journey it's
a very specific maneuver we need to
insert the spacecraft turn Jupiter so it
costs about one third of the fuel then
later on we need to orbit around the
image so we need also to be captured
around the anime so it's another
significant portion of the fuel and we
have some small maneuver or even there
on the orbit but most of the problems is
for insertion maneuver yeah well thanks
thanks so much for telling us all about
the uh it's an amazing spacecraft
apparently we've we're going to go over
to uh Susie over in uh over in new
nausea
is that not right
g'day Matt ah
hello Susie
we've got you back hello hello
so Susie hello Matt how are you very
well thank you so Susie how do we
communicate with a spacecraft that's
that far away
uh well the trick is you use a really
big antenna like we have here uh here's
one I prepared earlier so the whole idea
is the spacecraft can only carry a small
antenna so it can only have a a fairly
small amount of gain and a fairly small
amount of power because it all has to be
driven by the solar panels whereas here
on Earth we can have as big as big an
antenna as we like and we can use as
much power as we like so when we're
receiving from the antenna we use very
very uh sophisticated cryogenic
receivers in a large antenna and when
we're transmitting to the to the
spacecraft we just use brute force so we
just put up to 20 kilowatts of radio
power straight out through through the
antenna towards the end towards the
spacecraft and it all works
so can you give us some idea about you
know the the different sort of levels of
power that you're trying to receive and
because I'm sure I'm assuming these are
these are ridiculous numbers
yeah so uh an analogy is um if you're
standing on the surface of Mars and you
have a mobile phone now of course
assuming that your mobile phone is in
the frequency bands that we use for
space Communications which your mobile
phone isn't but if you had a mobile
phone on the surface of Mars we'd be
able to pick up that signal we have some
of the most sensitive receivers on the
face of the planet
oh so how long does it take a command to
actually reach the spacecraft because
you're not just receiving signals are
you you're actually able to talk to the
spacecraft as well and then hear back
from the spacecraft how long does that
whole process take and what are the
challenges there
that's
yeah so um one of the big problems here
is that the spacecraft is so far away so
it can take Jupiter in fact is anywhere
from around 40 to 50 minutes away at the
speed of light so of course the commands
travel out to Jupiter at the speed of
light so they'll get there in 40 or 50
minutes a response from the spacecraft
can take another 40 or 50 minutes to
come back so you're looking at around
trip time of an hour and a half so it's
um
one of the what one of the uh comments
that I've heard about deep space uh deep
space tracking actually uh from one of
my colleagues at Easter is that it's
sometimes like watching grass grow
because it's slow and methodical and uh
and you take your time talking to the
spacecraft
yeah can you describe the process of
sending commands is it different to
receiving commands what what's the uh
what's the is there any similarities and
differences what the main difference is
there
well it
so the main difference of course is when
we're receiving we're receiving very
small signals when we transmit back to
the spacecraft we use the same Hardware
we use all the same antenna and we use
the same feed horn we use the same
um most of the same much much the same
Electronics but of course instead of
having a very sensitive receiver we have
an extremely large powerful uh
transmitter and if you look at the base
of the antenna that you might be able to
see behind me we've got a big array of
Chiller equipment which is actually used
just to cool down the transmitters in
the in the um in the base of the antenna
because we use hundreds of kilowatts of
power to actually generate the generate
the signal that the spacecraft needs
uh so Susie I've got some more exciting
news from Bruno we're going straight to
Bruno in the main control room so Bruno
uh give us your update now please
so we've just reached the second most
critical milestone in this leop which is
the deployment of the solar race
just a couple of minutes ago
the last pyros that are cutting the
knives that's of the cables that hold
the solar rays have been fired have been
fired successfully
and you can see on the screen up there a
representation of this of the spacecraft
and the the panel on the left side has
just started to deploy on the left side
to that scheme you see the power
consumption and the power production of
the spacecraft the red line indicates
that we were consuming power from the
batteries that means we were negative it
was below the scale and the now the Blue
Line shows that the satellite has
started to produce its own electricity
so the solar panels on that side that
started to deploy
a number of the panels the subpanels are
already in there in their position they
are deployed they are not yet locked but
they're reaching there
I just got information that one of the
Wings now looks deployed at micro switch
level that means it's in its final
position
and you see the successful successively
the power starts increasing as each of
the panels unfolds I recall that these
are some of the largest solar panels
ever flown an interplanetary Mission
they have 27 meters from one Edge to the
other Edge in total they have an area of
85 square meters of solar panels close
to the Earth they are able to produce a
lot of power but once we get to to
Jupiter it will only produce a few
hundred Watts
nevertheless the process is ongoing this
is a very exciting moment for us if it
all works out if the two panels
successfully completely deploy we will
have a mission ready to fly to Jupiter
we will still need to do a lot of work
to configure the satellite for Crews and
to configure the satellite for the
commissioning phase that comes
afterwards that is the the phase where
we test all the equipment to make sure
that everything is still fully
functioning
but I I keep hearing my colleagues
saying that the switches keep
registering the the panels unfolding so
everything is going quite nominally at
this point
um it will take a few more minutes I
think we're almost ready the the wing on
the right side also started to deploy
nominally and some of the switches
already indicating that they are in the
deployed position
is the power increases steadily it will
not increase
[Music]
non-stop at one point it will reach the
limit that of power that the spacecraft
is able to consume and it will not
produce more than that it automatically
regulates itself only to produce as much
as the satellite needs although at this
distance from the Sun it is able to
produce a lot more
the batteries are already being
recharged so there is already an
excessive power coming from the solar
rays that allows us to refill the
batteries I recall you that the the
satellite has been working on batteries
ever since a few minutes before the
actual launch of Varian 5 we went to
internal power and the spacecraft has
been using its internal batteries to
keep everything up and running now it's
moving on to the solar rays it's
producing its own energy and it's able
to refill the batteries
confirmation minus y That's the side to
the right side of the of the spacecraft
minus y Wing has just also completely
deployed in micro switch level so this
is a good sign
of the solar array we have a mission
we're flying to Jupiter
[Applause]
get ready for this
I hope you just heard Andrea Komatsu
announcing on the briefing Loop that
Europe has a mission we are on our way
to Jupiter we have power
both solar raids are fully deployed the
satellite is fully functioning after a
little scare coming late to talk to us
the satellite is finally there and what
a beauty what a beauty what a great
satellite what a great Mission
congratulations to everybody involved
congratulations to the rocket to the
teams on the ground to the teams here at
isoc that are now taking control
um I I will hand it back to you Matt
there is not much to say we have a
fantastic Mission ongoing and what what
a pleasure what a pleasure has been to
share this moment with you
yeah absolutely absolutely the the the
early tents has made this all the more
all the better I mean I'm I've got a
little party going on in my room so
uh yes so I want to remind I mean it's
just how brilliant is this I want to
remind our Watchers that they can also
participate uh in this amazing day
simply use the hashtag ask Isa on social
media and we'll try and get your uh
questions answered uh we have uh one
actually coming in from uh Twitter uh
which is juices able to ex how is juice
able to explore Jupiter's moons in depth
while it remains in orbit uh it's a
great question uh and it's uh really
good timing because we've got Rosario
laurenti who is a real scientist uh
working in the juice science operations
center hello Rosario
so before we get to that question
actually of uh you know that how is it
able to do it let's let's talk about
this eight year Journey because this is
something else that's been coming up on
Twitter quite a lot is people asking you
know what are the scientists going to be
doing in this eight year journey and I'm
assuming you're not just going to be
sitting around drinking coffee so what
so what are you going to be doing in
this in this eight year stretch yeah
yeah you're right yes this is just the
starting point but we have to be
prepared and to prepare the instruments
to be sure that they are ready when you
when we arrive to Jupiter and one of the
things we will be doing is to prepare
all the scientific operations we will be
running when turning turning around
Jupiter why is this so important we know
already that these operations will be
really really intense and we know that
we have to do the best of every
opportunity we will have to look at
Jupiter to look at its moons its rings
its magnetosphere every character in
this super scenario and we know that we
we are flying one of the most powerful
payloads to be known already to the
outer solar system and for us it's like
organizing a super Orchestra and trying
to play a great Symphony with the best
instruments the best players and you
know it this is impossible without a
rehearsal without any script so for us
our symphony is the science Return of
the of the mission and we have to to
make the worst of it and yeah yeah I'm
actually being told that there's a an
announcement so I'm just going to pause
you just for a second before we get on
to the answer for the next Twitter one
and this announcement from karoo so
we're going to go over to karoon air So
Lisa are you over there in Peru
and yes we are here and I'm here with
Issa DG Joseph my goodness how are you
feeling right now oh my God how do I
feel I feel
very relieved it's just uh but I also
feel very proud for Europe and for
everyone who has contributed to this
Mission and let me really say a thank
you to all the people who have made
these possible this goes all the way
back for to member states making it a
decision that we are having such a
mission the scientists who have
conceived a mission and dreamed of the
impossible to go to Jupiter and really
find out is there a moon that could be
habitable and this is a question which
of course we're all asking ourselves and
now conceiving a mission that can
measure these parameters and then of
course the project teams are the
industry are all the companies all the
partners all the institutions have
contributed instruments I'm so grateful
and I really would like to thank them
from the bottom of my heart but also to
say you can really be so proud of having
this achieved let me also add a word of
thank you to our International Partners
so NASA is a very strong partner of
Eastland of Europe we have many
corporations and this is one of them
where NASA has provided one install in
particular but also our partners in
Japan jaxa has provided components to
the instruments the Israel space agency
has provided components so really this
is an international partnership but I
think it's also a moment of of Pride for
Europe and uh I really on behalf of all
these teams would like to thank everyone
who has made this possible and I'm just
relieved and just so happy well it's the
Delight to see your face and everyone
else's face here today it's a wonderful
wonderful warm feeling uh here inside
Jupiter and uh well thank you very much
Joseph and uh I hope I hope that the
rest of the mission goes as well hope of
course I mean there's still steps to
Undertaker we are in a celebratory mood
and I think we have good reasons because
because we had uh acquisition of signal
now the solar panels are opening of
course I have to remind everyone there's
still a long way to go and we have to
test all the instruments uh make sure
that they're functioned as expected and
then of course arrive in Jupiter measure
the moon so do all the trajectories to
get there so there's still a lot of work
to be done but the most critical one
which is the launcher the separation the
acquisition of signal all this has
happened and for this I think we have
really done a very big step towards
Jupiter future
in Jupiter in crew Raphael and me are
going to say a huge thank you to all the
teams here you don't see them but my
goodness they have been working so hard
to bring you this uh this show so we're
delighted to have been part of it thanks
to everyone thanks for watching and
Rafael well congratulations to my
wonderful colleagues and all the teams
involved in this Mission what an
incredible mission
and we
hand back to ESOP and they're going to I
think they have a surprise for you but
that may be later on we're going to hand
back to them for now over in darmstead
thanks for everything
thanks very much Lisa yeah what how
amazing congratulations to all those
teams and Well Done Ariane 5 for
delivering this payload special payload
into space what an amazing moment for
those who just joined us I I'm actually
in Germany where they actually fly these
spacecraft and out to Jupiter and I'm
with Rosario and we were just getting
onto a Twitter question which was how is
juice going to be able to explore the
moon's in depth when it's out at once
it's in orbit around Jupiter yeah
a funny way to look at this is to
imagine yours as a six Stone Beat the
Beast and the instruments as the as the
senses of this of this Beast and the way
it perceives the world and in particular
the the Jovian Moons for example the the
eyes of this Beast will be the remote
sensing instruments that will be
watching at the surface and the
atmospheres of the of the Moors and see
which is their composition and and the
processes that are going there are going
on there
um also when we will be close to the
months uh the the probe will wear
special goggles to see the surface in 3D
to see the the geology of the surface
and also to penetrate a few kilometers
and see how these first layers look like
it doesn't mean that we cannot go
further inside and see the the structure
inside the moon for this we have the
incito instruments that will be
continuously
smelling and and tasting the environment
touching the plasma the particles and
unfilling the magnetic field and the
radiation around the probe so everything
together also together with the the way
the the probe is feeling its weight with
respect to the gravitational pull it
receives from from the Moon the moon's
everything together will allow us to to
to understand the internal structure of
the of the moons and among other things
to know
why there are and and why and how and
where the oceans of liquid water are and
if there they are habitable yeah I mean
it's when you described it as an
orchestra getting ready it actually
sounds more like that you have to be an
orchestral musician and a ballet dancer
at the same time this is amazing so
you've got you've got all these science
objectives so is you know how how do you
do you how as a scientist do you deal
with all the expectations and how does
the spacecraft itself deal with all
those expectations and this this huge
orchestral complex piece that it has to
play when it gets out there yeah yeah
well we think that the hardest part of
this Orchestra is a two jungle between
what we want and what we can so on one
side we have our dream of unveiling some
of the secrets of Jupiter and you know
all the instruments want to play
together at the same time and as long as
possible because every single bit of
data is important for the science return
but on the other hand the spacecraft
imposses us a strong constraints and
this is because we have constraints on
Power and on data generation why is this
because we are at Jupiter and this means
that we are very far away from from the
Sun and even if we have this huge solar
panels that could power up several
houses on Earth they can only power up
something similar to a microwave at
Jupiter distances so you know sometimes
we have to to choose among the
instruments that can be switched on at
the same time on the other hand being a
Jupiter means that we are very far away
from the earth also and this means that
the data transfer is very slow for
example if we had a two-hour film on
board Jews it will take several days to
be transferred to the Earth so all in
all a lot of constraints that forces us
to to light than the the instrument
operations and to choose to to trade off
and and to to make hard decisions but
always trying to preserve the scientific
objectives yeah it's hugely complicated
I mean so that's why you need this eight
years it's actually quite convenient
that you've got all this planning time
you've got to be short at the end yes
yeah I know it's like anything isn't it
you think oh eight years I've got ages
no no no no it's all right yeah so yeah
what are the plans for you know all this
data coming back to work presumably
people are going to be pouring over this
for for years what what are the plans
for the data when it comes to gets back
once the data here the instrument themes
are the ones that know how to cook them
to be usable for for the scientists so
they will cook the the the data they
will be restored in an archive and then
they will be shared among the whole
Community to be exploited for the years
to come as you said and who knows to
inspire new missions to to revisit this
this
incredible
Mission world I mean I mean it's one
thing that it's yeah are there that
really strikes me that that these things
take a long time to develop well you
know we heard from Frederick take a long
time to develop and then it takes a long
time to get there and then it takes a
long time to actually process the data
this for some scientists this is this is
a life's work isn't it yeah so so do you
think there will be a juice moment do
you think you'll have a a moment where
you go oh this is amazing who knows who
knows yeah we heard of that there was
the the Galileo moment when us anesthena
was saying Galileo discovered Jupiter's
mons
we can think about a second Galileo
moment when the Galileo probe showed
that these walls are not as cold and as
dead and as inhospitable as it was
thought before and this changed
completely our understanding of the
universe and the way we search for life
beyond the Earth and who knows if we
will have a huge moment that will also
change completely our understanding of
the solar system
so let's hope for the best yeah
absolutely thank you so much Rosario for
giving us all that information about
juice it's what a warning incredible
mission for those who are just joining
us you can ask more questions of of more
of our guests and we'll try and get them
answered right now we've got a video to
show something about the teams that are
involved here at esoc and we're going to
have a special guest straight after that
to talk about that so hopefully we've
got a video now of the teams in esoc
[Applause]
[Music]
I have been working on this project
since it's very beginning in 2015. it's
2014. I started on the juice project
four years ago when I started with music
I have been working for use for the last
nine years for 10 years now it's it's
like my child
I started growing up and now now it's
and I remember the project manager
coming to me and saying michaella let's
go and have a look on the structure
panels in the clean room when I was
actually in front of the hardware I
visualized for the first time the beauty
of the juice satellite the first day in
which the computer arrangeable computer
arrived we put it on a bench and we turn
it on and we can start feeling the juice
a heartbeat
one of the best moments for me was to
run the magnetic text campaign in
airbags in Toulouse it was an unknown
some experience to work with a different
teams with the scientists and with a
completely Innovative measurement system
that worked flawlessly it's so rewarding
to see the deployment
here to lose you would just realize who
the achievement of this test so all the
efforts coming from Europe
[Music]
I think the biggest challenge for me was
to keep the schedule in order to be able
to meet the launch window that we had
so we had was the arrival of the food
it was one day later the rest went very
fine I think we've had quite a number of
hairy moments but we have had a very
good team on industry sites instrument
sites but also for either
[Music]
when I was a kid I was dreaming of
exploring the solar system and the deep
space like in a science fiction movie so
now working around an interplanetary
probe in the clear room knowing that I
can